hi guys i'm alvin and today i'm going to
be challenging myself to make a lower
calorie version
of the cheesecake factory famous fresh
strawberry slice
this video idea is heavily inspired by
joshua weissman he does improve versions
of fast foods and chain restaurant foods
shout out to him it's incredible work
the cheesecake factory slice has around
a thousand calories
based on the nutritional info provided
on their website i'm gonna see if i can
make a slice that is maybe
less than half so around 200 to 400
calories i know that's gonna be a big
jump but i'm excited to try the
challenge for my approach i'm gonna be
using a recipe adapt from erin clark of
well plated she has a recipe for a greek
yogurt cheesecake that looks really
promising i'm not trying to be healthy
or anything i just think it'd be a fun
challenge to see if it's possible to
even make a cheesecake slice
with significantly less calories so here
we go
so for the crust the original cheesecake
factory has graham crackers margarine
honey salt vanilla a bunch of other
stuff so for the crust
we're gonna go with just normal old good
graham cracker crumbs we're gonna add
melted butter
rather not sacrifice the flavor here and
try to look for other areas where maybe
we can substitute for some other stuff a
little bit of salt
usually a lot of cheesecake crust it's
graham cracker crumbs
butter and sugar i'm not gonna add sugar
because graham crackers already have
sugar in them so i'm gonna not add sugar
just to see if we can reduce
the calorie count this is a medium-ish
springform pan i like to use a glass to
push it around instead of using my hands
maybe the sugar isn't only there
for sweetness maybe it also adds kind of
like a binding element to the crust so
when it bakes it'll melt if the crust
suddenly you know collapses or stuff
like that my gut says it'll be because
of the sugar
but this is holding up well it's not
falling apart so let's put this in the
oven our lower calorie version adjusted
it and we turned it into graham crackers
butter
and salt 350 degrees
probably like 10 or 15 minutes until
it's brown and
time to go make the filling
the cheesecake factory original one had
cream cheese salt thickeners sour cream
whole eggs and sugar not too many crazy
things this is
16 ounces of reduced fat cream cheese
always do cream cheese
and sugar first this is why i beat the
cream cheese in the sugar first
you can see all these lumps kind of
forming already
this is pretty smooth so now we're gonna
add two cups
of non-fat greek yogurt yogurt it's
white it's thick
it almost has the same physical
properties as cream cheese
but yogurt compared to cream cheese has
way less calories
and also adds a really nice tang i'm
someone that likes
cheesecakes that are a little more on
the acidic or like the brighter side
this substitution is perfect for me this
texture is so beautiful
so now we're adding a couple of eggs and
eggs add nice flavors
to desserts which is why there's not
much of adjustment that we can make here
add some vanilla definitely looks like
cheesecake better
ours has a reduced fat cream cheese it
has sugar it has
greek yogurt non-fat it has eggs and
vanilla we're gonna add some lemon zest
just makes the whole thing smell taste
and feel a lot lighter
i'm feeling pretty optimistic about this
i just hope it doesn't like
explode in the oven for some reason time
to go get the crust
no it didn't break yes good job dude the
crust seemed to stay
intact it's crumbling a little bit so
the sugar probably would have helped
that but
i would say that's a good cheesecake
crust all right the only thing left is
to put the filling
inside of it this is probably one of my
favorite moments because you get this
waterfall ribbon of cheesecake filling
and it just
looks very pretty
[Music]
couldn't get the crust up that high
it'll still taste hopefully it tastes
good look at that
[Music]
all right let's go bake this baking this
one at 275
i'll check on you though please work
oh it kind of looks like the souffle oh
yeah
i think that is done and we are going to
take this
jiggly guy out whoa this is crazy it
kind of rose
that might be from the yogurt just
because the yogurt has a lot of water
and could evaporate
and make things rise i think this will
sink down though this is
really cool really interesting yeah i
guess we'll just let this hang out for a
couple of hours stick it in the fridge
and
we'll cut into it
[Music]
so i actually let this cool overnight it
kind of like shrunk down a bit in the
middle i think it just
arose a lot and then it went down a lot
it'll be a little bit messy but
i still think it'll taste really good
just open it up
yeah not the cleanest edges but that is
definitely
a cheesecake i'm gonna get this guy onto
a cutting board just to make sure
that we can go through evenly cut it
with
a knife in hot water the one from the
cheesecake factory
is pretty long it kind of goes more than
halfway i just want to make sure that
the proportions are the same
so that the comparisons are fair when it
comes to the calories wow
yeah look at that looks like a
legitimate
cheesecake i think the yogurt kept it
super moist all right let's
plate this thing up this is the one
by the cheesecake factory didn't
actually come with a whipped cream so i
just got
regular whipped cream from the store and
did a little swirl thing the one i made
this is the lower calorie cheesecake i'm
gonna try to make it
garnish the same way so that everything
sort of matches up the topping for the
strawberries the original cheesecake
factories topping has strawberries water
corn syrup cornstarch pectin citric acid
in order to sort of make a lower calorie
version of this instead of like making a
sugar syrup and like dunking it and like
making it
like a candy topping i think i can get
that same effect if i just brush honey
and i think
with the honey it'll also make the whole
cheesecake taste a lot lighter
instead of a full fat sort of whipped
topping i got some reduced fat or light
whipped topping which i think is pretty
much
fat-free i'm looking at it it's like 15
calories for two tablespoons so yeah
let's just go for it
oh that kind of went all over the place
so on this side this is the cheesecake
factory one the strawberry slice
it's just a straight up plastic
delicious cheesecake clay strawberry
some whipped cream
mine is a lower calorie with greek
yogurt with reduced fat whipped topping
and fresh strawberries with honey
instead of the syrup we are able to make
a big difference
and i'm excited to see how that's going
to taste
so i want to taste the cheesecake
factory one first this is the og one
that's very soft
okay it's very sweet definitely taste
the honey and the graham cracker base i
think these strawberries are a little
too sweet for me i think you know
depending on your mood this is like your
indulgence you just
want to go all out okay i have a good
idea of what this one tastes like now
i'm gonna eat
this one oh that's good the crust is
definitely not as sweet
a little bit more crumbly i think that's
because this other crust has sugar in it
although the crust isn't as sweet it
kind of makes you taste the cheesecake
more
which is really good i like the yogurt
and the yogurt and the lemon zest
really make this one like a lot lighter
personally
i like the lighter taste of this but if
you want something indulgent
this might not be for you the whipped
topping tastes the same
no big difference there i 100 like the
fresh strawberries with the honey
that freshness from the strawberry is
just so good it's a lot lighter you just
want to eat more of it like i'm doing
now like look at this
i am definitely on a big sugar rush
right now the original cheesecake
factory had about a thousand calories if
you ate the whole thing
and the one i made i think the end
result is about 300 to 400 for the slice
so
less than half which is crazy in terms
of components
crust on the original one tastes a lot
better i think without the sugar it's
just kind of this crumbly weird thing
which is fine i like the filling
on the cheesecake that is lower calorie
because of the yogurt and the way it has
more lemon for the topping i also think
fresh strawberries place a little bit of
honey i prefer that over
the strawberries in the little syrup
just because i like the fresh fruit
flavor
i am very surprised i didn't expect to
turn out this way i thought the lower
calorie version one
was gonna be a far jump away from the
original one both of these cheesecakes i
think are really great they're great for
certain
you know moods i think if you want an
adult you should eat the
original 1000 calorie one and if you
want to try something lighter
and try something more refreshing you
can try the lower calorie one but both
of these cheesecakes i think
are fantastic
[Music]
you